[Música]
y llegó el momento de hablar de revista
de prensa ya está lista conmigo en el
estudio rosa pérez más de euros a
bienvenida a feliz miércoles y feliz
mañana vamos a empezar hablando de la
prensa británica que abre con el voto de
confianza al que se enfrenta el primer
ministro boris johnson este miércoles en
la cámara de los comunes y empezamos
entonces rosa con the independent
buenos días raúl exactamente comentamos
esta portada que no sé si vamos a ver
aquí exactamente poco más hace falta
añadir a este titular que dice nadie me
avisó de que la fiesta iba en contra de
las normas dice el hombre que hizo las
normas en fin muy muy clara y muy s
destacable no esta declaración es de
boris johnson en todo este contexto
precisamente por eso vamos con el
artículo que hemos seleccionado de the
gardian radio de rosa y titula si me
permites voto de confianza renuncia
supervivencia que al espera a boris
johnson el artículo lo escribió peter
walker exacto éste a periodista político
de the gardian plantea cuatro escenarios
posibles
a desencadenarse a partir de la
situación actual en primer lugar plantea
que finalmente puede desencadenarse
efectivamente este voto de confianza y
que boris johnson pues puede ser que lo
acabe perdiendo en segundo lugar plantea
el escenario de la visita de los hombres
de traje gris que esto a la práctica
significa que la cúpula del partido
acabe pidiendo al primer ministro eso sí
de forma informal a puerta cerrada pues
que dimita en tercer lugar que boris
johnson acabe renunciando pues por su
propio pie porque según fuentes que cita
este periodista boris johnson puede ser
que no tenga el estómago para
enfrentarse a este voto de confianza si
finalmente queda claro ya previamente a
la votación de que la aritmética le
juega en contra y por último pues la
opción la cuarta opción sería que salga
impune de esta votación porque como
comenta este periodista peter walker y
boris johnson desafía constantemente las
reglas y aquí sigue y los británicos
nosotros se conforman las disculpas sino
que quieren su cabeza quieren la
renuncia de boris johnson vamos a seguir
con otros medios británicos rosas the
times y the song sí porque como venías
diciendo no la prensa británica está
enfocada en esto the times dice los
parlamentarios británicos se unen para
derrocar a boris johnson el primer
ministro busca evitar la rebelión
mientras algunos parlamentarios aseguran
que se alcanzará el umbral para provocar
el voto de confianza y finalmente the
sun dice díaz de para boris johnson pues
está un momento crucial en la política
del reino unido así es rosa y seguimos
en europa pero vamos a cambiar
radicalmente de tema un tema que me
parece muy interesante vamos con el
medio ruso de moscú time que aborda el
problema montañoso de la cripta
humanidad senior que un reportaje de
york y lisa med excepto es un país del
que poco acostumbramos a hablar aquí
pero básicamente lo que plantea este
reportaje es que georgia se ha
convertido en uno de los epicentros
mundiales de menaje de cripto monedas
que recordemos es este proceso de
validación de las transacciones de
cripto monedas para que se precisa de
ordenadores de alta potencia y también
de mucha potencia eléctrica porque
recordemos esto lo hacen usuarios
individuales este proceso está
descentralizado no pasa por los bancos
entonces lo que sucede es que georgia
plantea pues es una situación favorable
para las personas que desarrollan esta
actividad por un lado por las políticas
gubernamentales y por otro lado porque
el gobierno de georgia y subsidia
incluso da energía gratis a las zonas
montañosas remotas para evitar la
despoblación por lo que muchos
habitantes particularmente de la región
donde se centra este reportaje de vanity
se dedican a esta actividad provocando
cortes eléctricos pero raúl no te lo
pierdas también se benefician de estos
subsidios los monasterios pero el
gobierno no se quiere enfrentar no se
quiere confrontar contra la iglesia
ortodoxa pero sí que amenaza a la
población desván etic con eliminar estos
subsidios eléctricos y muchos
terminarían siendo mineros de cripto
monedas rozamos antes que se nos acaben
nuestra sección con el desconcierto en
chile- urgencia inmediata
otra chica los proyectos que piñera
busca aprobar a última hora antes de ser
a de poder eso es este es un texto de
eme dj fresas y édgar feelings que bueno
los alentamos a que entren en el
desconcierto a leerlo porque realmente
es muy detallado y analizado con
distintos expertos pero básicamente
comenta los 27 proyectos de ley que
piñera quiere tramitar de forma urgente
quiere acelerar en el congreso para pues
llevarlos a cabo antes de que termine su
mandato recordemos que ya el 11 de marzo
tiene lugar la toma de posesión de
gabriel boric el presidente electo de
chile rosa gracias entonces por toda la
información esta revista al prensa de
hoy miércoles mañana con más de revista
de prensa pasamos ahora a hablar con
nuestro primer invitado el día